[Music]
what was your worst first date my worst
first date worst first worst first date
I feel like I was out with this girl and
it was one of the situations where I
really had to like pull all the
conversation out of her like she wasn't
talking so I ended up really frustrated
and then trying to make her like
embarrassed because I got so just
irritated that so like because she
wasn't saying anything and she just like
wasn't giving anything so I well then I
got up and I was like no no she wants to
go the bathroom I was like all right
cool have a good pool you wanna pull
co-co-co have a good wide on't you just
end it and go oh I got something to do a
guy take my dog to the groomers I mean I
still wanted to eat the what the booty
nah Japanese food now she's gonna be
pilling oh I take that back I backwards
date was this girl I was out with her
and then she was she was looking at a
picture of herself and she went I'm so
photogenic cute yes I know you can be
hard as [ __ ] what if you do that [ __ ]
I'm like nah man your personality so can
I finish it is but if she was hot you
can kind of tolerate a little bit but
she just said he's a mean side visit if
she's hot she could literally spit on a
homeless person I wouldn't care because
she's doing it to me some
self-empowering [ __ ] but what he said
was she's I not she was she was pretty
but then her attitude made her I wasn't
so hot that I would put up with the
[ __ ] to potentially somebody on her
I was I would put up with so much
[ __ ] to get laid especially there
was everything like she could be a
serial killer and I'm like huh what if
she was a bank robber Oh was he and he
was a bank robber it's insured money to
bet that's sexy and he's fine as [ __ ]
that's like Daniel Ocean from ocean
zenith Ben Affleck have a movie like
that yeah ready yeah oh I thought you
were getting your Whitey's confused and
I was like
damn man that was you eating your
Whitey's confused yeah I guess you're
right you sure whatever your name is
it's it they're both in it right who let
him answer and he was wrong the whole
time and everyone like acted for you
well we all have listened to jela as
usual but no we adult that's how Matt
Damon silent well let's move on okay so
in Massachusetts this is Jeremy Renner
another whitey true Ben Affleck's named
it in the town he directed it it's Casey
yeah okay well he's in the town did you
watch the town he's the star of the town
and it was Jeremy Renner you did see a
movie listen it's somebody talk about
movies that you didn't even know why be
able to look to save their names are the
same
Jason Bateman and that Damon look the
same that's like a nerd
Matt Damon sexy right yeah see I think I
got you okay
listen a Massachusetts woman became an
unexpected getaway driver after she met
you earlier on a dating app for the
first time they met and then he was like
oh well first of all she picks him up at
his mom's house and then he is telling
her to like they drove about 30 minutes
and then she said that he was drinking
wine in the passenger seat of her that's
on maximum what a fancy robber
this is [ __ ] Nissan add what the [ __ ]
they mentioned it's I thought you should
get the whole picture so he's drinking
and driving
no no she was did he come out in a wine
glass like this like a fat [ __ ] steer
so she's drinking and driving no so
there's three red flags already the
first one is
she has to pick him up yes right and
then not only she picking him up she's
thinking of it from his mom's house and
he's drinking by himself I think that's
really bad but it's not as bad as saying
you seen the he came with declarative
[ __ ] statements he never talks like
that either the old maybe that's a meal
he'll keep his Carol head and his turtle
don't make it on his own the only time
he has a camera on him to it was it was
bad but then one day we finally put the
camera ok let me give you a story
deflected then like I said they had
never met in person before that day and
so she's driving for about thirty
minutes and that's when this guy asked
her to pull over as they were
approaching a bank so he gets out of the
car he left her there alone for a few
minutes and then suddenly came running
back sweating with his sunglasses a hat
and a gun and a thousand dollars in cash
and that's why she told her [ __ ] go
so she panicked cuz he had a gun and
[ __ ] and so she took off but then there
were cops chasing them and that's when
she pulled over walked away from the car
and then he stayed inside the car and he
was ducking from the police until
finally they were able to apprehend him
they violently struggled and he spit on
them and told them that his gun wasn't
loaded but then finally he was subdued
and no it's too bit she pulled over she
didn't even like stick with the plan
what a bad first date yeah you say it
doctor come you gotta commit to that I
mean he got the money to spend on her
right that's what I was soo min like
only a thousand bucks though first date
you've been on only a thousand my first
date jail that's a lot of money to spend
on a first date that is not my goals and
I want an overachiever okay true it
should be on
half a mil thank you minimum she fell Oh
get over yourself there's so many [ __ ]
hookers you can get for way cheaper yeah
who would [ __ ] destroy both of you at
the same time or like for only $1,000
what kind of hookers do you know Oh all
kind of hooker yeah I don't know why
that knows a guy that knows a guy yeah I
know the guy who I think I know that you
know I just know the hooker you just cut
to the chase why I only heard good hope
you do you know I know the guy and the
guy knows the guy I know the guy that
knows the guy that goes down story up to
you in real life not on camera let me
get ready I'll change you don't change
the mechanics oil doing it that day okay
you know you you know I don't now I'm
genuinely curious we'll see like it's
like beautiful hard and she was really
nice and we were slow but wait
yeah we're friends people are after oh
no like after I painted up right Peter
yeah no no this is like a long time ago
in a galaxy far away right okay I was
telling you so the reason why this
information leaked out is is all talking
to David about this [ __ ] cuz I was
talking about how crazy
like I get when I'm just like on this
animal level I can't control myself I'll
gamble I'll do whatever such an animal
in the heat of the moment for some odd
reason I just found I eat some [ __ ] so
I just went down with a [ __ ] hooker
for 30 minutes love [ __ ] I'm just
exaggerating it was probably like five
but it's not like that what it felt like
30 because I got to my senses and I was
like what am i doing well yes I can't
have your back on this one you guys you
get we have to start normalizing sex
workers okay I hate stigma that we have
we need to start normalizing to your
point
who would have a cleaner [ __ ] than a
hooker because it's she's protecting
herself the whole shift that day what
what if she had an eight-hour shift that
day and Joe is number eight but it's
still all protected [ __ ] doesn't happen
oh yeah oh no Joe was it causing y'all
come on it was a nighttime that's
irrelevant
what was that 7:00 a.m. it was a busy
Sunday [ __ ] I don't know well dude
that's like leftover chicken bro it
Chipotle it's a noob it's a new batch of
chicken for every customers what y'all
don't realize I love to wait the extra
three mystery wants to show how
passionate I am can we focus on that can
we focus on the positives you guys are
just all [ __ ] up
yes I'm a passionate mother [ __ ]
that's what I realized I give okay I am
a giver I
selfish right all you guys are selfish
because the first thing you guys started
thinking about was let me get my [ __ ]
hey the massage [ __ ] therapist to
massage them that's what I'm that kind
of [ __ ] you bring in a plate of
chicken to the Popeyes employee pay for
lap dance and give her a motivational
speech that's the kind of [ __ ] I am
yeah you're the guy who gets a lot debt
and he's like he's like I [ __ ] love
you I think we're really connecting
definitely you know you seen yet the
circle what I owe you guys and I just
watched like a perfect jack off in the
corner so accurate it is
because I'm a giver I'm not a taker dude
what are you talking about this guy's a
legend okay don't [ __ ] happened like
years ago it's like a different person
anyway I don't give a [ __ ] that's old
Joe right [ __ ] is that that Joe is like
you guys will be in a time machine
different race when you when you put it
the way you put it it is kind of like
you know at first it's like oh god why
would you eat out a hooker right but
then it's like you think about it and
the hookers are you know they have to
protect themselves all day oh damn
[ __ ] they want to keep having a
career they have to protect themselves
so they don't catch no diseases that's a
clean pool between a girl that
professionally cleans her [ __ ] versus
someone you don't know where she's just
[ __ ] alive she's that she's [ __ ] for
free
that's a fair point she's [ __ ] for
free but she [ __ ] just as many guys yes
maybe not that many but I think the
variants maybe is maybe it but how do
you know like if you told me I gotta
share a sandwich with a bunch of people
I think I'm less down to do that with
then with somebody who just but
according to Dan you're cutting off the
piece that they just were yes you have a
Tim and Joe with all due respect to the
guys subway on a Monday morning and they
ordered the [ __ ] tuna fish sandwich
look at the dolls over the weekend dude
it's so good let me tell you something
though I gambled and I want cuz I've
done multiple blood tests
good clean baby good that's good you
know what the hooker says she's like I
don't know he has 30 minutes I didn't
even come I just sat there
[Laughter]
[Music]